salut à tous et envergure on est de
retour pour parler de la course offer
speak nba 2022 après che tonnes grain le
profil de paolo banque quéro je précise
que cet épisode a été enregistré avant
la loterie on va donc faire des
suppositions mais surtout à faire son
profil technique physique psychologique
c'est parti c'est envergure génériques
ben steve alan bonsoir messieurs
conforte soit paulo banque héros donc le
joueur de duke duke qui n'a pas réussi à
offrir un coach qui est là le farewell
tour qui qu'il voulait puisqu'ils ont
été éliminés
aux portes aux portes du titre quasiment
aux portes du titre nba mais qui a quand
même fait une grosse saison grâce
notamment à paolo gontero il y avait
aussi wendell moore et jack griffin
trésor qu'ils marquent williams que des
joueurs qui pourraient être drafté au
premier tour en juin prochain on va donc
commencer par parler du parcours par
contre comme on a l'habitude le parcours
l'histoire de paolo gontero alan c'est
toi qui t'y coll d'où vient-il ce jeune
homme il vient d'une région qui commença
historiquement sortir énormément de
basketteur c'est le nord ouest des états
unis donc la région de l'état du
washington
c'est un joueur donc comme tu dis qu'il
ya une famille de sportifs des mémoires
le papa a joué au baseball donc pas le
pain pas le basket mais il ya de la ja
de la aventure pas grande sportive
familiale dans ce camp diversifiée et
lui c'est aussi un sportif très
diversifiés pour le gang qui revient
c'est pas déjà les deux seules villes en
termes de football américain mais
c'était aussi un très bon joueur de
football américain
au lycée mais en fait son parcours
sportif att qu'il a été vraiment embêté
par le cos vide je pense que c'est des
choses qu'il faut surtout mettre en
avant il ya dans les dates du washington
ça a été très compliqué pour les
compétitions en intra lycéenne pour les
youyous et tout ça et donc il n'a pas
joué de match quasiment officiel pendant
très longtemps ce qui apparemment on
peut freiner sa progression mais qu'il a
aussi permis de travailler vraiment de
son côté et pour arriver à duke
extrêmement près comme chet comme
jabbari les cursus honorum complet comme
j'aime bien dire il a été il ajouté
il aurait été mal temps american si le
match avait eu deux et tout ça il a été
un des meilleurs freshman de tout là de
toutes les initiés c'est à dire des même
un des meilleurs joueur show plein ciel
il faut dire du côté du but et voit la
famille de sportifs petit gène donc
italien qui est un peu marrant par le
non c'est pas trop comment de prononcer
et tout ça mais aussi semé une bête
athlétique qui a fait plusieurs sports
et qui a excédé stan est justement
parlons de ses capacités athlétiques de
ses mensurations aussi au niveau de
l'âge il aura 20 ans en fin d'année chez
plus si les 2 novembre octobre chez
plumer mais pour l'instant il est encore
19 ans mais il est par exemple de deux
ans en tout cas il est 2002 voilà il
n'est pas dit les pas de 2003 comme
jabbari semé de 2002 et les joueurs les
plus jeunes de cette draft seront de
2003 steve le corps le l'athlète qui est
paulo bang héros corporellement donc il
est il est grand de m 08 massif 113 kg
et relativement long l'envergure situant
à peu près entre 2014 et 2016 fonction
des sources après à calais principales
qualités de son corps c'est digéré sa
mobilité c'est un joueur c'est à dire
qu'il y court il bouge très bien dans
l'espace par rapport à son corps il ya
une vraie maîtrise de son corps dans
l'espace par rapport à son gabarit il
est toujours très équilibré et il a une
énorme qualité athlétique on en parlera
sans doute plus tard ses appuis vraiment
un super travail d'appuis j'ai joueurs
là très à l'aise sur les appuis
au niveau du la musculature c'est un
joueur qui est assez costaud surtout sur
le haut du corps il absorbe plutôt bien
le contact assez solide il a un centre
de gravité assez bas je trouve ce qui
lui permet plutôt bien tourné les
hanches pareil ça à un enjeu ça en
défense notamment sur la sur la question
des demis match après des prêts des
switchs niveau de la détente c'est pas
le joueur le plus vertical qui puisse
avoir en universitaire mais c'est quand
même un garçon qui montrent assez au
cercle cas un très bon second saut je
trouve dans mon sur les robots offre aux
tirs at il remonte très très vite et
c'est qu'à passer la remontée vite au
cercle et si je devrais mettre un petit
bémol ce serait plutôt sur le premier
pas ou c'est pas un joueur qui a une
vraie capacité à franchir très très
forte même si c bon premier pack emmené
ce n'est pas un premier pas exceptionnel
mais c'est à relativiser par le fait qu'
il fait quand même centre c'est en somme
c'est un très bon athlète qui est
complètement une bière et 10 pour moi
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas demander à
un 36 tonnes de démarrer aussi vite
qu'une fiat quoi si on devait faire de
faire ce genre de comparaison automobile
italienne en plus
il est naturalisé italien
c'est important de préciser donc il va
peut-être faire des compètes fiba il
faut savoir que son deuxième prénom
c'est napoléon donc il est prêt à
conques et hop voilà
c'est ça il n'est pas corsi italien du
coup
mon ben c'est à toi de me dire pourquoi
c'est un top prospects paulo bancaire où
on a parlé de son histoire on a parlé de
son enveloppe corporelle maintenant
parle moi de ses qualités de basketteur
principal on rentrera dans le détail
après belge doit premièrement réaffirmé
qu' on achète tout d'abord un profil
physique absolument incroyable c'est
quelqu'un qui peut bouger qui est qui
non seulement qui massif mais qui peut
très bien bouger donc il peut se rendre
absolument partout sur le terrain et
aussi il aimerait bien que ce soit pas
totalement là il projette comme un
scoreur ce qu'on appelle à trois niveaux
qui peuvent scorer au cercle à mi
distance et à trois points le tir à
trois points particulièrement est un peu
désordonné cette année mais sinon moi ce
que j'achète offensivement surtout c'est
sa capacité à se rendre au serbe qui est
absolument incroyable il a un spin move
qui est déjà des literies met tout le
monde dans la laveuse un cycle et spin
président près du panier c'est vraiment
très impressionnant à voir
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui aurait touché
je sais qu'on aime beaucoup ce mode en
général dans le monde du karting
d'inventer des des talents de passeur à
des des joueurs d'intérieur mais lui
c'est quelqu'un va toucher c'est qu'il
ya un vrai touche et donc qu'ils
projettent pas essentiellement aussi
pour être
l'initiateur
mais c'est quelqu'un d'entier d'y
toucher c'est toucher à la passe à la
passe exactement exactement qui fait des
virées lecture de jeu
qui ne panique pas sous pression non
plus c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui est un vrai touche et donc
j'aime beaucoup aussi ses passes à
partir du haut du cercle c'est à dire je
serai au point le plus loin où est-ce
qu'on a deux tirs à trois points il est
très capable de commandes de de passer
et de du post bas et d'en dehors de la
raquette toujours très impressionnant
pour moi c'est détroit
des trois
districts du trio de joie qui peut
potentiellement être drafté premier chat
jabbari et par l'eau c'est lui qui est
le plafond le plus haut il a peut-être
pas le plancher le plus beau mais si
tout fonctionne bien le plafond le plus
haut
pic
voilà comment je suis pas si c'est une
robe steak bah je sais pas je ne sais
pas je
réfléchis en ce moment la question je en
train de refaire mon big band
est ce qu'on peut parler de ce qui est à
l'intérieur de sa tête maintenant qu'on
a dressé un peu la carte d'identité
l'attitude déjà steve sur le terrain
est ce que c'est un leader par la voix
par l'exemple parler d'eux comment il
réagit face à l'adversité qu'est ce que
tu peux me dire du genre au delà de sa
personnalité sur le terrain sur le
terrain c'est un joueur plutôt discret
calme pas très extraverti et les leaders
surtout par le par le jeu sur le terrain
certes il a une grande capacité j'ai
trouvé cette saison très capable de
hausser son niveau de jeu quand l'équipe
en avait besoin de prendre ses
responsabilités et a contrario quand
l'équipe tourne bien il avait aussi
cette capacité tout à fait de laisser le
jeu à ses coéquipiers c'est que j'ai
bien apprécié presse est pas un joueur
qui est parti sur mon avocat j'ai trouvé
voilà qui
valent au cabba qui a pas donné
l'impression non plus de d'être
insatisfait de son rôle dans l'équipe
bien intégré au collectif voilà
il fait
j'aime bien ses mimiques mois quand il
répond en interview il fait vachement il
fait vachement le gars matures le gain
est un peu dur là on peut en parler avec
cette vidéo incroyable où il est
confondu avec patrice pomès et donc il
est par un journaliste de formule 1
qu'on peut aisément pardonner du coup
ben qu'est ce que tu en penses toi de
ceux de ses interviews que tu as vu
juste
steve a parlé du terrain hors terrain
je sais pas encore il m'a l'air un peu
plus dans la moyenne des joueurs
qui m'avait qui me plus impressionné si
vous avez moins de joie sadiki
la cassette pour la plusieurs les
professeurs de ces joueurs là la
cassette des médias embarque un très
jeune âge je trouve que pour queiroz un
peu de recul comme et en même temps il
était dans l'oeil des médias depuis que
quoi 15 16 ans donc je pense qu'on peut
lui pardonner non mais mentalement pour
moi
j'ai
quelques réserves sur ce que j'ai vu en
défensive avec avec duke parce que c'est
pas un joueur qui physiquement ne peut
pas compétitionner en défensive c'est un
choix qui physiquement qui mentalement
perdait complètement la carte de caisse
qui est en train de se passer sur le
terrain donc
c'est je pense que ce que ce que
justement le côté non vocale que steve
dont six par les mois je
sais qu'ils vont peut-être sans un
certain manque de maturité jusqu'à un
certain point n'est pas un manque de
maturité
comportementale mais un manque de
maturité côté basque est ce à dire qu'il
ya tellement jamais eu besoin de
ça qui strient
systématiquement de toutes ses
responsabilités que des fois justement
quand qui voit quelque chose qui est un
peu moins sa responsabilité selon lui il
part dans sa bulle puis ça fonctionne
plus c'est compliqué et défendre au
basket oui donc donc sauce un médiateur
côté
alors ça ça peut être aussi expliquer
puisque comme tu le dit très bien c'est
compliqué de défendre il est plus
difficile d'apprendre à d'appréhender un
schéma défensif collectif que offensif
surtout quand tu as le talent de paolo
banque héros c'est à dire que
offensivement on va te donner le ballon
et tu vas faire des choses défensivement
va attendre de toit des décisions
et comme disait alan il a raté beaucoup
de compétition à cause à cause de la
pandémie donc ça 7 je dis pas que ça
explique tout mais je dis que ça peut
expliquer alan pourquoi est ce qu'il est
un initiateur principal paulo banque
héros est ce qu'il est le meilleur
joueur
d'une bonne équipe en tout cas le
premier attaquant anglais 1 bis c'est la
seule question c'est une question si on
le dragon numéro 1 aussi
j'ai après volée sur la question je
t'aurais dit non il ya un vrai nom en
janvier et en fait sa fin d'année m'a
vraiment
reprendre en confiance en ses capacités
de création pour moi c'est alors oui il
ya quelqu'un d'autre ou john monteiro
c'est le meilleur passeur de la gr
franchement du dureau de la drache ses
qualités de plémet king est passé de son
assez fun surtout quand on fait le
rapport
poids taille qu à taipei les making
c'est comme j'ai déjà barry smith le tir
pourquoi cette demi-heure shooter dallas
parce qu'en plus c'est taille par
rapport aux shoots et je trouve que la
qualité de passe de paolo woods quiros
et la vision notamment comme l'a dit
comme l'a dit mais après des spin move
dans la zone intermédiaire elle est
assez incroyable et en fait
la question vous pas ce
fait tous les initiateurs qui
réussissent sur une bielle et initiateur
d'élite ils ont une couleur de l'eau il
ya que jim butler qui par moment arriva
à le faire mais c'est pas vraiment un
des initiateurs sur
un réalisateur comme on les entend il
faut voir sur le blog de loin notamment
à trois points pour pouvoir ensuite être
défendus différemment et exprimer ses
qualités de passes notamment sur pick'n
roll et tous à la question ça va être ce
qu'il est ce qu'il a ce tir et ski la
stir parce que j étais de passe il les a
la capacité d'aller au cirque et de
secret les paniers faciles qui conte les
initiateurs il m'a dit franchement il
est assez même s'il n'a pas le meilleur
premier pas est tellement puissant
tellement tonique je trouve que il peut
se créé pas mal de choses faciles douala
et joue t il aller demain il a le
dribble pu faire ça non il a pas encore
mais brest n'a pas vraiment la fluidité
des deux mains et l'a pas le pouleuf de
loin mais on a un joueur qui allait
quand même qu'ils fine qui finissait
quasiment 53% à 2 points qui allait
quasiment 5 qui ajouté quasiment cinq
lancers francs par match qui sur
l'ensemble de la saison faisait
quasiment 10 et 18 % et positive de son
équipe avec
dans un rôle où voilà alors c'était pas
17h primaire fanta dans la march madness
c'était au début des essais plus ou
moins d'elle moore après c'était plus
sûr et miro trouve pas en moi qui gère
un petit peu la création lui était un
peu dans ce rôle secondaire
je ne vois pas très bon je dis juste que
j'ai un peu évolué sur la question et je
suis je pense qu'il peut lille peut être
un bon initiateurs et une bille et
primaires je ne sais pas il y en a 10 15
quoi donc mais en fait j'ai joué j'ai
plus confiance et qui a été de
l'initiation qu'avant ben je te donnerai
la parole après sur le tir puissant
c'est ce qu'alain a mis en point
d'interrogation
mais mais je vais donner la parole à
steve sur la défense
pour compléter cette année ils défendent
est sûr qu'ils aient à ton avis il peut
défendre sur qui à terme et surtout dans
quel rôle est ce que c'est un gars qu'on
va mettre sur le ballon est ce qu'on va
mettre loin du ballon mais ce que loin
du ballon il aura un impact
ce genre de questions cette saison elle
a défendu essentiellement sur son
vis-à-vis et pas énormément mais
justement par rapport à lui donc il
défendait sur des postes 4 en général
donc il était sur un général plus grand
que ses adversaires directs plus costaud
et il était très con il est intéressant
sur la défense porter et où il se met un
petit peu en action mais comme vous
disiez sur la défense non porteurs tout
ce qui est les rotations défensives les
aides défensives c'est un peu compliqué
c'est quelques flashs en protection de
cercle mais c'est pas ça pas là dessus
qu'il va être intéressant il a il a
défendu pas mal aussi bas je le défends
aussi pas mal sûr du switch on parle de
communication défensive lui il passe son
temps à demander le switch justement
c'est un truc ça tout le temps et il
s'est retrouvé à défendre sur des petits
sans être absolument ridicule parce que
mobilité fait que que ça va mais c'est
pas non plus un joueur de switch purge
pensent ils à il est dans une équipe
aussi on a parlé de son parcours où
effectivement il a pas eu besoin de
défendre et l'ail dans une équipe aussi
il ya beaucoup de bons défenseurs et
donc je pense aussi que c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on lui demandait en
priorité voilà donc ces deux raisons
aussi il était pas non plus très engagé
dans la défense parce que il jouait avec
trailer qui lissent mark williams des
joueurs qui défendent très bien loin des
amours junior ou même griffin donc m'a
énormément responsabiliser sur les
défenses voilà et effectivement pour la
saison régulière ça posera pas de
problème mais pour les playoffs va
falloir qu'ils soient qu'ils soient peu
plus conscience hurle sur les rotations
défensives sur la défense au moins un an
porteurs à l'opposé de la balle parce
que pour l'instant il n'est pas du tout
pas du tout dans les schémas défensifs
mais il pourrait y lire les formats
davantage comment s'il est choisi dans
le top 3 l'avantagent c'est que il
devra peut-être un peu patienter avant
de voir les playoffs puisque c'est assez
récent fond du classement aux playoffs
tout de suite ben sur le tir quelle
variété comment tu trouves sa gestuelle
est ce que voilà et il a des préférences
motrices je reçois la balle d'un côté un
des choses dont on parlait dans le
podcast par exemple sur sur jeddah navy
hughes avait bien expliqué voilà j'ai
donné vie à un peu plus de mal à tirer
quand la balle vient de chez plus sa
gauche ou à droite mais mais voilà c est
ce que toi tu 8 roi et où et pourquoi en
déroulant les capacités techniques
oui je crois qu'il va donner un bon
shooteur nba mais comme je me tiens en
parlant de cette classe de draft les
joueurs qui vont devenir des knock down
shooter à nba dans cette classe là il y
en a pas beaucoup donc je crois que je
crois que par le maintenir au pour
s'élever à des pourcentages qui sont
corrects surtout à deux points c'est un
shooteur à
2.2 de carrière de curry ce qu'il aime
c'est ce qui est à quoi il est
confortable son pôle up paddle point
c'est extrêmement propre ça va être un
exemple d'une comparaison un peu
boiteuse lamela seul le seul joueur qui
me vient en tête qui avait un colloque
par deux points au sit in que ça c'est
john wall
les deux joueurs absolument par rapport
à l'autre mais mes yeux un peu près le
même pour l'heure pas de coups et les
espèces de
webos qui fait complètement automatique
je le trouve un peu lourdaud à trois
points surtout un peu en situation de
création pour lui même ça va lentement
ya polaire
je veux que je vais dire quelque chose
qui va avoir l'air très controversé
georges et écouter votre opinion là
dessus j'ai l'impression que c'est une
question q ui une question deux pour
reconnaître le moment où il doit shooter
et de reconnaître c'est fini tu
d'occasion à savoir ajouté j'ai
l'impression que je suis souvent très
très tard qui dribble vraiment
beaucoup quand vient le temps de créer
pour le moins
l'impression peut être une question de
qi mais aussi fou d'expérience selon
c'est selon mais aussi une question de
confiance it a cité la famille tt shoot
parce que quand il est en rythme il les
prend il n'hésite pas et il est bon
d'ailleurs quand ils arrivent en
transition et qu'on lui file la balle il
fait ils plantent les deux appuis il
n'est pas sur un europe comme job ariste
mais si les plus sûres droite gauche
banques et
ouais et c'est soit qu'ils vont jouer
avec un meilleur l'initiateur à une
biellette on pense quoi du tir et steve
aussi brillant way sur le mid règne que
que sur le mid rennes j'ai sur le lancer
franc on a un joueur qui pourra oublier
il fait quasiment 2 10
c'est quasiment de dizy fait plus de 110
kg
c'est quand même assez solide est plutôt
fluide troupes pour son âge
et sa taille la question sera de wayne
qui a pouvoir un peu c'est garder mais
les joueurs certains joueurs vivent
quand même pas mal sur le mid règne
après pour être capable de prendre du 3
points club pour ouvrir un peu le jeu
mais moi franchement sur l'année j'ai
trouvé qu'il était de plus en plus en
confiance sur ce tir alors au début je
trouvais la mécanique pas incroyable
j'ai trouvé un petit peu freak l1 je
trouve qu'il ya un peuple d'un coût de
quelque chose un peu un peu dans son
bras je trouvais que c'était pas
extrêmement naturelle mais ça reste un
joueur qui était à quasiment 1 3 73%
lancers francs pas mal sur votre kazim
dans la moye la moyenne à 30 cents à 1 à
3 points à son âge on se penche dans un
space thing par incroyable même si
franchement pour être honnête duke
c'était mieux que les années précédentes
un même à l'initiation ou un des leurs
avait dressé
je me rappelle de l'épisode qu'on ait
fait à deux ans sur wayne d'aider
l'équipe de duke ou avec wendell moore
et tout ça il a bien bien progresser
jeremy road side a progressé aussi donc
franchement s'il n'était pas extrêmement
bien servi mais ça allait saleh il est
oui explique simon il est excellent sur
cinq sont assez performants sur les sur
les transitions ou là il est pro tout de
suite quand il arrive de face en général
gomis et stop sur un arrêt le terreau
natif y monte je vous rejoins sur le sur
le club à mi distance
vraiment il est hyper efficace là dessus
après pour le tir à trois points aux la
gestuelle ça manque parfois un peu de
fluidité le tir est parfois un peu plat
mais je pense qu'il va progresser j'ai
je suis pas persuadé qu'ils puissent
vraiment être sûr du tir à trois-points
sortie de dribble par contre est ce
efficace sur du catch and shoot pour
être une menace en tout cas crédits
spéciaux dans son équipe je pense que
oui a du travail ça devrait le faire je
pense qu'aussi avec son poids sa
puissance c'est peut-être plus difficile
pour lui de shooter après des
déplacements latéraux gelé peu vu faire
ça et et autant il se situe très bien
après son spin move donc il a des supers
appuyé ce que tu disais steve en
introduction c'est vrai il a un jeu de
jambes de deux boxeurs quoi mais
mais je sais pas je les peins je n'ai
pas vraiment vu faire des side step ou
ce genre de choses n'avaient pas
beaucoup besoin aussi avec avec ses
qualités athlétiques mais mais c'est
quelque chose peut-être à surveiller ou
à développer si on a un staff nba bns
qui peut et est-ce qu'il peut jouer sans
ballon notre ami paolo baisse est la
question
c'est la question est-ce qui peut jouer
sans ballon et sert à quoi sur le ballon
ce qui peut ce qui peut shooter est ce
qu ils peuvent shooter un sortie des
crises qui peuvent s'ajouter un catch
and shoot je sais pas vraiment pas
justement c'est un peu à lui et quand on
parle aux banques héros ce qui va faire
éditer des équipes c'est que c'est un
peu un contre consignes avec son
ensemble c'est à dire que si on le draft
on décide de le vouloir de vouloir toute
sa valeur si on lui donne le ballon si
on lui donne le ballon puis on le laisse
cuisiner comme on le dit si bien les
anglais mais sans balle et
honnêtement il paraît qu'ils vont nous
surprendre peut-être qu'il va nous
surprendre peut-être qu'il touche à tout
ça dans son jeu mais comme se disait les
en sortie de en sortie d'écran
latéral c'est ça la plus difficile donc
je sais pas pour moi c'est la clé
banques et vos situe le draft tu le mets
à lui donne les clefs de la voiture
moi je
fantasme ans que d'un rôle en poseur
d'écran un peu et ensuite prise de
décision
lancée parce que comme c'est un très bon
passeur et comme on peut peut-être alors
ça nécessitera aussi peut-être que l on
ait peur du but tir parce que quand il
ya un klose out qui est sur les
potentiels pick and pop mais en fait
c'est tellement bon pasteur j'ai trouvé
que quand il a joué syracuse notamment
ou quand il a joué un moment texas tech
et qui avait de la zone j'ai trouvé
super bon dans la capacité à trouver son
intérieur sur des fautes il feinte à
gauche qui passait en bas à droite ou
des jeux des renversements peut être
qu'en poseurs d'écran avec un bon
parterre de pick and roll il pourrait
prendre des décisions et là c'est pas
vraiment c'est pas vraiment loin du
ballon mais c'est une utilisation
différente que juste du post up des
choses comme ça c'est intéressant aussi
simplement parce que aujourd'hui en nba
de plus en plus des équipes par petites
séquences vont faire de la zone
lors des zones très hybride mais mes
services des zones où il faudra être le
choix de joueurs qui ont un potentiel
d'obtenir kingsey jeu syracuse dans
l'année c'est un match à regarder parce
que
parce que sur l'après jabbari spyder
paris faisait un bon match là dessus sur
la prise de décision c'est horrible
quand ils ont des joueurs a coûté la
défense mais écoute et qu'on trouve
c'est toujours intéressant steve on
parlait un peu rapidement du contexte
tout à l'heure est ce que pour toi sale
a servi ou salade est servi et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut retirer de ça parce qu'il
avait à côté de lui un très très bon
protecteur de cercles de mark williams
vraiment très très long vous pouvez
écoutez notre podcast sur lui mais en
gros quand il lève les bras il est à 10
cm du cercle donkey
quand il saute c'est difficile de passer
au dessus à côté de lui il avait mark
williams à l'intérieur allait lille
avait une d'elles moore riggi griffin
donc d'aider des gros dégâts imposant
mais qui peuvent shooter aussi pas mal
de spacing est-ce que c'était pas
finalement le contexte presque idéale
adiu qui manquait peut-être juste
finalement un gros meneur de jeu mais il
y en a peu en m6 web c'est un bon compte
est pour moi parce que il a il a appris
à jouer en équipe aussi il faut savoir
que bah il sait pas un sport collectif
aux lycéens joue tout seul il jouer
contre personne il joue avec personne
donc les grosses craintes mois que
j'avais quand j'avais un petit peu
regardé avant de préparer un article sur
duke c'est que niveau de la prise de
décisions c'était catastrophique qui
faisait n'importe quoi mais là il a fait
le choix de rejoindre une des équipes
que plus de talent et du coup même si
les responsabiliser ce qu'il a à peu
près afin de 7% de taux d' usage il a
quand même obligé de faire jouer les
copains d'être dans des collaborations
et je pense que dans sa formation de
basketteur c'est un très bon choix il
aurait pu faire un choix inverse comme
patrick baldwin aller dans une fac un
peu moins avec moins de talent et puis
mettre plus de points et s'exposer un
peu plus mais dans l'idée d'une
formation de basketteur pour se préparer
pour une bière je sais c'est un très
très bon contexte mon choix bent est
d'accord avec ça oui absolument
absolument je crois qu'il va pas tarder
meilleur contexte en biais pour lui
surtout dans le top 5 mais
oui mais quel métier je trouve je trouve
style un peu dur avec son avec son
analyse de héros ou au lycée parce que
c'est un peu le code tous les joueurs
avec un physique nba parce que soit le
futur on dit souvent dans le milieu du
karting le fut le physique on peut pas
l'enseigné vous donc les joies qui sont
quittés qui arrive à 6 8 6 9 à l'âge de
15 16 ans il joue tout seul chemin parce
qu'ils jouent ils jouent tous une bande
de jeunes qui font genre 5 et 8 5 et 9
donc ouais mais oui je pense que
justement son sont touchés c'est très
développé puis je crois que c'est encore
prêt
embryonnaire chez
justement le jeu l'équipe le désire
aussi comme un collectif
alan quel bon contexte dans le haut de
la draft quel bon contexte pour lui quel
est ce qu'on le met à côté d'un mark
williams en mieux puisque avec déjà
d'expérience elle sait ce qu'on le met à
côté d'un stretch pour jouer d'un guide
un mec qui se traitent chemin grand qui
stretch qu'est ce qu'il faut dans
l'idéal
le contexte idéal c'est mais s'il
contaste plus rare c'est côté d'un
stretch protecteur de cercle parce que
comme ça il n'a pas besoin de protéger
le cercle et d'un et de l'autre côté il
peut se retrouver dans un quasi avec les
quatre joueurs allaient me à 3 points
elle lui il est tout seul pour attaquer
le panier et là ils te détruit les le
circle adverse moi je pense que yann à
indiana l'épaisseur avec mike turner ah
oui c'est avec halliburton et mode
stoner ça peut être
vraiment top mondial est un bon contexte
pour beaucoup de joueurs en nettement je
trouve mais franchement oui je pense que
lui
offensivement il a peut-être moins moi
mon besoin il a besoin spacing parce que
c'est un joueur qui n'est pas le plus
tranchant balle en main et qui n'a pas
non plus la menace du poulet pas très
bon mais qu'il a vu sur d'une migraine
est sûre de la taille de siècle faut pas
non plus que le panier soit à qui que ce
soit comme quand quand tu y as i drive à
oklahoma state se retrouver avec et
qu'une armée d'une armée de branleurs
mais
je pense qu'il a c'est un cercle dans
pas mal de systèmes dans le début de
carrière on va pas lui demander de
gagner des matches je pense qu'on va eut
demandé d'arriver en pas influé sur 6 1
ouais indiana n'a jamais l'habitude de
tanks et de toujours et au moins passe
en plus donc c'est vrai que les kindia
nass&wind on s'amuse jouer avec
halliburton mike holmes rock dance y
restent y joe warren mal ce turner
prêteront tonga zahia jackson chris
duarte tout ça c'est sûr que c'est un
cd bons joueurs donc ça n'aide pas au
logo qui rasa jackson donnez donnez
donnez moi un stylo de stylos ou est ce
que je dois aussi
ouais ben tu dis toi tu étais des fans
du contexte à indiana indiana qui adore
le sixième meilleure chance d'avoir rien
ou 5e chez plus 5e ils ont mis la gomme
sur la fin pour way
d'avoir le first pick effectivement est
ce que l'un d'entre vous à quelque chose
a ajouté qu'il avait dans ses notes de
ce casting sur parle aux banques et rock
band chéreau
je trouve juste que cet épisode plus que
d'autres il a vraiment progressé chou
voilà je trouve que les progrès étaient
vraiment notable donc non pas mal de
choses et pour un freshman
c'est normal il progresse toussaint de
semaine en semaine à cet âge là c'est
normal surtout pour lui qui sortait de
pas mal de période sera jouée mais par
le gong héros qui est pourtant
incroyable le premier soir au madison
square garden contre kenzy qui par
rapport à celui de find and hate final
fort et où quittait cover mélange entre
michigan state quand sont un peu mal
dans la march madness qui fut mémorable
entre carolina y voit il a passé le
ballon ils se font éliminer par north
carolina il a passé le ballon mais c'est
quand on lui donne il y va il met
désormais les profils des changes et du
salon belle progression stable à 10,2 le
mettra souvent nous mettra souvent venus
en exactement avec qui suit beaucoup là
ici mais je trouve que il a été vraiment
sur une pente ascendante sur sur la vie
dans son jeu offensif tu as vu un joueur
qui évolue et steve oui toute la saison
et l'adresse il a j'ai pas les chiffres
mais sur les 10 11 derniers matchs ils
étaient beaucoup plus adroits à trois
points sur ces bennes parlé de ses
prises de sa prise de décision pareil je
trouve qu'il était plus intelligent sur
la fin de saison il faisait des
meilleurs choix donc clairement il a
vraiment évolué tout au long de la
saison ou plus il n'a jamais été blessé
la toujours un vrai temps de jeu donc ça
a été constant c'était une saison pleine
quoi absolument paulo band hero donc
lee l'américano italien ou
l'italo-américain on s'est pas encore
tue en train de chercher les splits pour
con pour conclure ce ce podcast mai mais
je me perds sur le site de sport de
référence donc on vous ils sont
certainement dans le scouting de report
on voulait mettra en tout cas dans notre
prochain scouting report
messieurs merci beaucoup pour votre
analyse nous avons respecté le timing et
le contrat portrait de draft de futurs
drafté paulo bancaire au futur top 3 les
top 5 pour pas se mouiller et on vous
donne rendez-vous pour pour tous nos
contenus avant draft
ddd live des d'autres podcast évidemment
des mauves draft des big board et
scouting les forces de tout ce que vous
voulez c'est sur les plateformes des
coudes que vous choisissez c'est sur
notre site envergure comment ces eaux là
tout est agrégé et puis c'est également
sur sur youtube sur les réseaux sociaux
twitter
installez vous pouvez rejoindre si vous
voulez discuter papoter avec nous en
dehors de nos heures de podcasts on est
sûr discorde également donc voilà je
crois que j'étais complet et vous l'avez
été sur paolo gontero alan ben steve
merci les gars et les rapports entre
lens et zhao